I'm not saying necessarily that it's too
late to you know fix the country it's
never too late to do anything what I'm
saying is that it's probably too late to
stop what was about to happen
widespread violence and destruction sure
and if we and if we don't blow it that's
already happening there's already wives
but pan I know and just 54 days right
come on man we're talking about thirty
four hours of cannon fire now that's
impressive but it's still a day and a
half right
how about 54 days 54 nights to be fair
right it's the nights when they of when
they actually start rioting of riots
what's call all right like think about
it historically when they say 454 night
longer than that now it's gonna it's
gonna go on for what till November until
Trump finally retreats and they take the
Federal Building
think about what history would say if
Trump retreats they would say for 73
days insurrectionists besieged a federal
building until finally the federal
authorities under President Trump
retreated they took the building and
destroyed it signaling the you know the
capture of federal jurisdiction you know
so here's what I think the big fear is
that as China seeks to displace us as
the world's superpower we war will break
out if we're too busy fighting amongst
amongst ourselves there won't be a war
or maybe there still could be
I'm sure that's what they hope for yep
silver spiked earlier today it's really
interesting I don't know enough about
the markets you know if interesting talk
somebody about precious metals but
Gold's been going up you know and that
basically as far as I know is not a good
sign for the dollar was it who was it
recently who said Peter Shapiro Schiff
said this was gonna be like a dollar
shortage or crisis or something yeah
well he was talking about at the same
time you were you're like I think the
dollar was gonna crash I think that's
the end of the US economy and he was
tweeting it as we were talking about it
I thought it was funny I think with
these coin shortages a lot of stores
have stopped kicking taking cash out
right it's getting really interesting
really really interesting I hope you've
all geared up and gotten ready for
November November 4th is going to be the
most interesting day of our lives I
would imagine straight-up the time that
the clock is ticking you know we're now
just a little bit over three months a
little bit over three months about three
and a half months yeah they're firing on
all cylinders man everyone everything is
happening right now
I'm gonna enjoy my last Halloween it's
gonna be fun that's that's that's
depressing dude you're what you get you
can be a little depressing sometime the
last Halloween yeah just in general you
can be a little depressing why what you
would you just say where I'm gonna enjoy
my last Halloween yeah that's that's
depressing dude well hey man okay no no
no no no I'm not gonna accept that sorry
no I'm telling you you're wrong
right now we're gonna have other
Halloween's life's gonna continue on
these these people that are that
everyone's standing up right now and and
everyone's ready to fight I think you
take it way too seriously when I say
last Halloween I can't take things it's
hard for me to not be serious anymore I
know I loved a joke I love to have a
good time you know but the more I look
into this and the more I understand the
gravity of what is happening right now
all of us should be we should be this
aware and we should know how serious it
is it's hard for me to just switch it
from this is really serious civil war
people are trying to bring down America
and then like crack jokes it's it's it's
not easy for me to do that anymore
because also I'll say it right back man
that's depressing okay if I maybe maybe
it is if I make if I make a joke about
the last Halloween because November 4th
is gonna be the day of chaos yeah I'm
not literally saying Halloween will
never happen again
well I'm just telling you how I feel man
it's it's just exaggeration about the
severity of what's to come right okay
and and it is and you know what men like
when I look around this at this country
and the talk of the silent majority I
crossed my fingers but it's funny how
the left has this view of Trump
supporters as these like the meme is the
guy in the rascal with his belly hanging
out he's got to full-auto guns and like
nachos in front of them and he says
America yeah yeah I wish I wish we had
even a handful of those guys who loved
America so much they gorged themselves
and drove around with guns and a rascal
doesn't exist you've got a bunch of
chill people who want to live their life
work hard feed their family do their
thing you know they love and respect
this country for it it is but they are
not
going out screaming murica at the top of
their lungs with full auto guns no
they're researching laws reach it
researching how to get into the
government and actually make an actual
change and not screeching and throwing
bombs at a courthouse and that's what
I'm seeing I'm seeing people actually
going out and working towards making a
difference legally and that's that's the
Majoris islet majority you're talking
about and that's why they're losing that
in Shapiro said that trying to get a
pullet I'm gonna paraphrase him so
hopefully I'm getting it right but he
said something akin to trying to win a
political victory while they've taken
over the cultural institutions is
rearranging the chairs on the Titanic
and I completely agree okay Breitbart
said it a decade ago you know he's the
one who said it right politics right
politics is downstream from culture yeah
and so you you look at what the left has
done consistently Barack Obama was a
celebrity they loved that guy big old
charismatic smile on his face well he
enacted the NDAA indefinite detention
provisions and did all these horrible
horrible horrible things yesterday and
he got away with it because he he was
part of the dominant cultural
institutions so now you have Twitter
YouTube Facebook and we're lucky to be
on these platforms you're right and I'm
glad we were able to be here so I can
actually give my views out there I mean
yep just today just this morning I woke
up in someone tagged me like yo tim's
tim's video about all these leftists
going to the right running tamago and
the democrats are freaking out was was
trending in gaming so weird no it's not
known it's not weird turning in gaming
no I I it's not weird because the Pete
the gaming industry itself has been
infected by sjw's I'm a gamer I know
yeah many gamers are fed up with it
they're like redbull like for example
it's like redbull sells sugar drinks why
should it matter what they're but you
know they're yes like that's all it is
it's like gamers want to go to a game
and an escape for the fact that there
are not even allowed to escape in their
games means it's not working anymore and
this started about seven years ago
so congregate yeah a First Battle of the
of the cultural civil well that makes
sense because they're the younger
generation that you're saying called
politics is downhill from culture well
that culture is is is has
in attacked for so long now that you
know they think that they have all the
the new generation on their side well
that is not true it's not well so this
is why you were dangerous yeah sure
that's because people have said it to me
then whatever I'm not gonna stop talking
I did say you should write I won't so so
we were talking was earlier and I was
like I'll be as flattering as possible
you've got Adam Craig ler who's male
model Pro skateboarding rock star who
all of a sudden now is coming out and
being like go Trump but you are you you
develop all of these important cultural
things yeah the idea of like pro a pro
skateboarding rock star that's like what
every kid wanted to be 20 30 years ago
you know is like you know being a famous
musician and being a pro skater all
these things right and so that's culture
conservatives went for the political
victory but like Ben Shapiro said
rearrange in deck chairs on the Titanic
right so they won congratulations in
2016 they controlled all branches of the
government they then lost it in 2018
well when we talked about it though they
locked him down they they froze it all
so they couldn't do anything but it's
because they control the newspapers
that's true they can do exactly as the
TV shows and a lot of of people are now
realizing because of kovat they don't
have jobs a lot of people are stuck at
home they can't go out there's no sports
what are they doing they're watching the
mainstream media listening to the
president speak going back and
cross-checking themselves now and seeing
what is what are they talking about now
instead of having to do you know the few
people defend him like oh you're gonna
make me defend Trump now everyone's like
oh yeah okay you don't have to him
anymore because I can see for myself
people are seeing for themselves when
Trump was doing daily press briefings
his approval numbers were higher in the
aggregate than they have ever been and
why do you think he's gonna start doing
again he's starting he's gonna start him
up again because I'm not gonna cover it
they accuse him of lying all that stuff
so anyway that the ultimate point is
Republicans and conservatives need to be
fighting on the cultural front and they
started doing that with memes on the
Internet and then the left which
controls the platforms with which this
communication happens
nuked every single one of them that's
correct just they were like purge and so
here's what happens with the best
example I believe is probably the Donald
yeah there was a study done but I think
was MIT review that found that fortune
and the Donald were the progenitors of
the most prolific memes on the Internet
seriously just all the jokes everything
you would see yeah came from 4chan or
the Donald so what do they do they
accuse the Donald of all this wrongdoing
of all this manipulation and maybe some
of it's true I don't know I Madden
investigated so I'm not gonna tell like
I did it okay
but they then quarantined the Donald
under false pretenses they were
threatening police they said you think
the blue lives matter people were
threatening the cops not in the
slightest that's insane
I agree and so what's what a lot of
people the Donald thought was that you
get some far leftists who invade post
these things and then before they can
even realize they exist the admins go
look at this you should have got rid of
it quarantined
so they created their own website The
Donald dot win which is now probably one
of the biggest Pro Trump forums
considered the Donald itself has been
banned permanently no they were they
were gone for four months for four
months this the reddit the the Donald
was inactive and then the CEO comes out
and says we're banning all these
subreddits including the Donald because
they broke the rules but no one had
posted for four months it was locked
down which means they retro actively
applied new rules to an old forum you
know which shows there's literally
nothing you can do they snap their
fingers and they nuke you now what's
going on DDoS attacks against the Donald
dot win they're making it you can try
and pulp the website periodically and it
won't work mom they're just you can't
open it because a denial of service
attack is slamming into it so they're
trying really hard to shut them down you
know and now that they can't control
them directly because they've created
their own website people are going after
them indirectly so I'll tell you what
man I'm surprised we're still lucky
enough to be able to speak but I think
it's because we follow the rules you
know we're we're not overly overly
bombastic we don't insult we don't swear
we play it very very safe and it makes
it very difficult but they're gonna try
man you know they're gonna start
snipping up bits and out of context
they're gonna start pulling up your old
post and trying to figure out anything
they can get from you that's ever been
offensive whatever find a way to get
ripped to get rid of the things we were
talking about because they have to purge
the ideas yep thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you